prisión preventiva sin fianza para Dani
Alves por presunta violación es El
veredicto de una jueza de Barcelona tras
considerar que existe riesgo de fuga
luego de conocerse la noticia su actual
club El Pumas mexicano ha rescindido su
contrato con esta decisión el club
reitera su compromiso de no tolerar
actos de ningún integrante de nuestra
institución
sea quien sea que atenten contra el
espíritu universitario y sus valores la
decisión judicial llega por petición del
fiscal y de la defensa luego de escuchar
los testimonios de la víctima y del
futbolista el de ella concuerda con los
registros de las cámaras de una
discoteca de Barcelona el pasado 30 de
diciembre Dani Alves parece
contradecirse sea quien sea el presunto
agresor la ley solo Sí o sí protege a
todas las mujeres las mujeres que sufren
cualquier tipo de violencia sexual
cuentan con la protección del Estado
solo si es sí un lema feminista que se
convirtió en ley en agosto de 2022
España un texto por el que la ministra
de igualdad Irene Montero ha recibido
duros ataques de la oposición de
derechas la ley Busca aumentar la
atención y protección a las víctimas con
ella Alves enfrentará a una posible pena
de entre 4 y 12 años de